bonjour raphaël constants bonjour merci
de m'inviter avocat ancien bâtonnier du
barreau de fort de france et militants
peut-être plus militant d'une justice
différentes dans nos pays à la lecture
d'un texte que vous avez publié au cours
du week-end passé première question
révèle constante
existe-t-il une justice système
judiciaire différenciés selon qu'on soit
à paris lyon marseille nantes strasbourg
et à fort-de-france issia martinique il
y à une pratique pénale différentes par
sûrement ce qui concerne ce volet
essentiel de la répression contre 3 à
paris qu'on s'a à marseille ou contre en
martinique vous donne raison très simple
c'est qu'un société martiniquaise n'est
pas la société marseillaise n'est pas la
société barisienne qu'elle est
sociologiquement différentes par exemple
vous que vous sachiez que en martinique
par relativement il y a environ 30 à 40
% de délits plus important qu'en france
ce qui pose des problèmes qu aujourd'hui
au tribunal de grande instance de fort
de france
un volet pénal nettement plus important
que n'importe quel tribunaux de france
et de navarre
il sera une incidence sur ces magistrats
qui arriva martinique en général pour
quelques années
je pense surtout qu'il ya un autre
aspect qui les choque quand ils arrivent
pour lesquels ils n'ont pas
d'explication et de compréhension parce
qu'ils sont pas formés pour ça c'est
qu'une grande proportion des infractions
sont commises chez nous qui sont liées à
la violence en les vidant que dans notre
société un rapport à la violence et un
passage à l'acte est de nature
différente parce que nous ne sommes
société avec une histoire différente et
l'évident que le réflexe du magistrat et
de s'étonner et de vouloir réprimer
peut-être de manière plus systématique
que ce qui se passe en france alors
conséquences conséquence ces magistrats
selon vous
veulent punir très sévèrement et ne vont
pas jusqu'au bout de certains dossiers
sensibles comme c'est peut-être qu'il ya
mis le feu aux poudres chez vous appelle
constants cette affaire à des suites de
green parrot a qualifié de marie jeanne
alors j'ai écrit ce d'artigues mais les
idées que je défends je les défends
depuis des années même quand j'étais
passionné j'ai été extrêmement choqué
que le premier président et le procureur
jna les deux plus hauts personnages
issus en martinique et cru bon de
répondre à un député qui a fait une
déclaration
on va pouvoir préciser les choses on va
préciser les choses raphaël constant
tout simplement alfred marie-jeanne
critiquer le dépaysement de son dossier
dans le sud de la fère et green parrot
parler de justice rendue en martinique
de manière discriminatoire ce qui a
provoqué la cette réaction de gilles
rosati premier président de la cour
d'appel et de berna rabatel pour que
voir général absolument alors mesure à
vatel c'était pas la première fois il
avait déjà eu l'occasion de répliquer à
marie-jeanne il ya de cela quelques mois
comme marie jeanne avait critiqué et le
procureur de la république
mais que le juge à la limite de p&g
j'allais dire qu'il est dans son rôle
il est la partie poursuivante ans c'est
pas quelqu'un de neutre c'est un
fonctionnaire de justice qui agit dans
kadirov chic en revanche que celui qui
est censé être indépendant à savoir le
premier président mel sa plume avec le
bouquet orange général ça me choque
d'autant plus que ce qu'ils disent c'est
le droit selon vous de réagir à des
propos d'un frais de marie jeanne non ce
qui lui assure un traitement le sur une
posture vraiment politique
alors ils ont parfaitement le droit je
le reconnais je veux pas leur interdire
de parler ce que je suis étonné c'est
que deux magistrats qui sont différents
lors du siège et un du parquet estime de
s'exprimer publiquement
ce qui montre quand même le caractère
extrêmement particulier c'est comme si
vous aviez en france le président de la
contestation et le procureur général qui
allait répondre à françois hollande -
mini ce qui aurait fait une critique
soit malien de la justice fonctionne et
c'est quand même exceptionnel et un
deuxième aspect qu'est ce qu'ils disent
ils disent que les propos du député que
vous citez et sont outranciers
parce que la justice serait vendu
normalement martinique
or la pratique monde démontre le
contraire
jonas est ce que sous l'aspect pénal
dans le dossier que vous dites mais il
ya un exemple très simple
en martinique il ya mille détenus ducos
déborde du corps sont ni torture on y
viol chaque matin et chaque journée qui
passe dans ce pays
les droits les plus élémentaires ça ne
soulève pas les moins d'eau qu'un mec
justice michel finalement ce sont les
conditions de détention les conditions
par exemple 600 personnes c'est à dire
que c'est la pire prison de france selon
l'observatoire international des prisons
mais le raisonnement je veux tenir n'est
même pas celui-là outre cela il ya mille
c'est à dire qu'en martinique vous avez
un détenus pour 400 personnes si vous
reporter sa la population française ça
signifie qu'en france y aurait cent
cinquante mille détenus orient n'a même
pas 310000 c'est à dire qu'en martinique
ya deux fois et demie plus de tenue
qu'en france c'est la réalité concrète
mathématiques c'est dû à croix est-ce
qu'on a un gène est ce qu'on a une
situation non ses partenaires une
politique pénale
ici plus répressives ou de manière
systématique on incarcère et on ne prend
pas en compte la prévention
vous ne dites pas que saint raphaël
constant vous dis tout simplement que
ces magistrats pourraient effectivement
s'intéresse aux conditions de détention
et de vie à la prison de disco de ducos
vous leur dis très clairement aussi
qu'il pourrait mener certaines enquêtes
de façon plus plus objective plus
pointus par exemple dans cette affaire
green parrot toujours qui est parti on
le rappelle d'une lettre anonyme
aujourd'hui on dépayse la faire mais on
ne sait pas toujours qui a écrit cette
lettre à l'omi a manifestement le
parquet depuis 2009 a refusé quand les
partis ont déposé une plainte en
diffamation
c'est d'ailleurs frampton les deux marie
jeanne ont déposé une plainte en
diffamation et qu'on n'a pas retrouvé
l'auteur on a trouvé des diffuseurs de
cette lettre il y avait parmi eux en
responsable de aux partis politiques en
martinique
opposé à celui d'alfred jarry surveiller
de manière systématique le parquet
lui qui ne sera pas bon suer devant le
tribunal et quand le juge d'instruction
l'a quand même renvoyé devant le
tribunal
on a obtenu sa relaxe et il a fallu
aller devant la cour d'appel c'est le
militant de la justice qui s'exprime le
militant politique toute façon il est
très difficile que toi totalement
schizophrène je suis à la fois un avocat
et en même temps qu'un militant
politique connue comme membres du piquet
elle s est indépendante doit fermer
alors pour vous cette justice est
vraiment discriminatoire ici à
fort-de-france jeudi que la justice de
la manière dont elle rendu est
dramatique pour la société martiniquaise
parce qu'il faut savoir que 1000 détenus
ces mille familles qui sont concernées
c'est des milliers de gens qui sont
touchés directement et que la question
de la répression qui est quelque chose
de fondamental dans un processus social
de sanction de la contravention par
rapport à ce qui se passe dans une
société si elle est banalisée comme
aujourd'hui la baneza n'y a plus de sens
mais surtout il faut qu'on se croise
aussi d'accord sur un point il faut
savoir que la répression et les chiffres
sont là montrent que plus on réprime
plus il ya de la délinquance à ja ne
diminue pas elle continue et surtout
elle devient de plus en plus violente
c'est à dire la politique met en place
en martinique a pour but excusez moi
l'expression elle est peut-être choquant
de nous à mach jamaica lisez ces
chamailleries secrètement de fer qu'on
ait bientôt des bandes des gones en
martinique
et ça c'est la politique pénale c'est
l'absence de toute prévention
vous prenez la production judiciaire de
la jeunesse elle n'a pas cette personne
vous prenez le spip le service de
probation et non pas cette personne
pourquoi parce que l'objectif c'est de
mettre en prison et de ne pas prévenir
la présence donc vous partez de la
sphère marie jeanne pour dénoncer tout
système judiciaire absolument la firme
argenson épiphénomène comme il ya eu
dans toute l'histoire des procès
politiques cette rallonge hamza bouteraa
est censuré mais il ya une politique
quotidienne qui concerne le jeune martin
xe et surtout ce qu'il faut retenir de
votre courrier je souhaite qu'on
retienne de mobilier qu'il faut
réfléchir fondamentalement à la manière
dont la justice est rendue en martinique
parce qu'elle crée actuellement une
situation extrêmement et on va vers
l'irréversible à savoir que notre
jeunesse
une partie d'entre elles est en train de
se de devenir une délinquance d'habitude
mais vous dites aussi que la justice à
protéger un hiérarque du parti opposé
alfred marie-jeanne jeudi que le
procureur a voulu premièrement et a
écrit qu'il serait un non lieu
le concernant le juge d'instruction n'a
pas suivi que devant le tribunal le
procureur a souhaité sa relaxe et
l'obtenu et qu'il a fallu qu'on fasse
appel et que c'est seulement la cour
d'appel qui a reconnu que cette personne
avec au mieux le délit de diffamation à
l'encontre de frampton et des deux
marie-jeanne puisque nous sommes entre
nous cette demande de dépaysement
respire une peur celle du ridicule
vous le croyez ah oui je pense que la
première devant la population
martiniquaise il est plus facile parce
que quand ça va être dans une salle à
paris aura pas grand monde sinon les
journalistes mais devant des centaines
de martinique est allé raconter ce qu'on
veut raconter à savoir qu'il y aurait eu
des détournements ou bien une une prise
illégale d'intérêt pour des deux écoles
qui existe c'est quelque part que la
justice eut être rendue en tenant compte
d'une certaine pression populaire
non mais la question de la pression
populaire c'est pas ça ce que je veux
dire c'est que la justice normalement
pour qu'elle soit normal il faut qu'elle
soit publique et en général on juge les
gens là où il aurait commis les faits et
non pas on va plus loin à 7000
kilomètres pour en douce essayé je ne
sais pas trop quoi faire
la justice doit être en lumière et quand
on demande le dépaysement
je pense que c'est un acte de méfiance
par seulement plus à vis du peuple
martiniquais
mais même des magistrats du siège du
tribunal de grande instance de
fort-de-france
parce que la raison pour laquelle on a
demandé dépaysement c'est officiellement
parce que la défense avait adopté une
stratégie de déstabilisation
parce que manifestement il sent qu'on
souhaite que la défense elle soit béni
oui oui de connivence qu'on n'ait pas de
connivence
même si chacun a sa manière de
s'exprimer et on défend un homme ou une
femme
or vert secondes raphaël constants que
peut faire que peut faire des
martiniquais face à ce système
judiciaire qui n'est pas fiable selon
vous alors moi ce que je peux penser la
première chose qu'il faut une réflexion
sur la violence dans notre pays il faut
qu'on se pose une question sur la
nécessité
dès l'école de poser sa problématique et
ont fui au niveau de la justice
elle-même
il faut adopter une politique avant tout
de prévention surtout la justice pour
les mineurs
merci d'avoir ici ce matin avec nous
dans ce sens qu'a dit raphaël constant
avocat ancien bâtonnier du barreau de
fort-de-france et militants ont leur
souffle
merci d'avoir été avec nous bonne
journée